[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the beginning of the
kyrie from the setting of the requiem
mass by
thomas luis de victoria a spanish
composer and priest
writing at the beginning of the 17th
century his requiem
represents one of the pinnacles of
catholic polyphony it's also a dark
troubling very beautiful and
harmonically adventurous work
and you heard it there sung by what was
at the time unquestionably the finest
boys choir in the entire catholic church
the modern equivalent of the sistine
chapel i'm referring to westminster
cathedral choir
conducted there by david hill back in
1987.
happier times for this great choir and i
say that because
for a number of years the future of the
choir as the very finest in the entire
catholic church
has been under threat and it is
threatened by none other
than westminster cathedral itself and
the choir school which was set up
to educate and train the choristers and
that is a tragic state of affairs
the most immediate threat is to the
musical standards of the choir itself
whose repertoire incredibly complex
polyphony enchant
requires virtuosic skill on the part of
the boys
and therefore very intense practice
the 20 or so boy choristers who now make
up only
10 of the choir school's pupils are its
only
borders and until recently they were
full-time borders
because if you ask any of the cathedrals
former masters of music they will tell
you that
the boys must practice on saturdays and
must be on residence on saturday night
sunday morning
in order that they can tackle the most
important service of the week
solomon massa the cathedral which they
have to save
masses chants responses motets
that are simply beyond the capabilities
of an ordinary choir
only two other boys cars in london are
in the same league those are westminster
abbey and some pools
and their repertoire is simply not as
daunting as that of westminster
cathedral where the boys sing in latin
have to master these astonishing
multi-layered polyphonic motets
and indeed have done such worldwide
acclaim for decades
the choir famously has its own sound
which is different from that
of the great anglican cathedral choirs
where the sound is perhaps
a bit easier on the ear because the
repertoire is perhaps less challenging
or at least
challenging in a different way standards
at westminster abbey and some pools are
just as high however and one reason for
that
is that they too insist on full-time
boarding on intensive rehearsals
just for the big sunday service anyway
last year the headmaster of the choir
school
neil mclaughlin decided to end weekly
boarding
the chorus just went home on saturdays
and came back on sunday mornings
the much of my master of music at the
cathedral martin baker said this would
have a disastrous effect on performance
and when he wasn't listened to he
suddenly left his job
no explanation was given by the
cathedral but baker was
not there for the christmas services at
westminster cathedral
the musical world and by that i don't
just mean the catholic musical world and
i don't just mean the world of cathedral
music
was horrified two of britain's leading
composers
sir james macmillan and michael barkley
now lord barkley
went to see cardinal nichols and pleaded
with him to change his mind
but nichols stuck by the very ambitious
choir school and it's very ambitious
headmaster and by ambitious i mean i
think
socially and academically ambitious not
particularly interested in the music
then when the outcry continued the
cardinal said he'd have a strategic
review to
discuss the implications of the changes
but nobody expects very much from it and
the damage is done martin baker has gone
he hasn't been replaced
his deputy peter stevens is doing a
fantastic job
with a choir which even before covid had
been depleted
and whose standards were audibly
slipping
now covid of course is actually rather
convenient for all sorts of
institutions which are failing at their
job and are looking for a handy excuse
and i think westminster cathedral which
has reacted quite hysterically to the
pandemic
keeping its doors close for as long as
possible driving away as many visitors
as possible
was hoping it could just blame the virus
so nichols and mclachlan must have been
absolutely furious when
last week the controversy blew up again
it was revealed that madeleine smith
the very successful music administrator
of westminster cathedral has resigned
from her job
and not only that but written a very
long and damning letter
which was first leaked onto social media
by me
and has now been picked up by the times
newspaper
the paper's religious affairs
correspondent kaya burgess
reported on saturday that madeleine
smith resigned with a letter that made
allegations about a toxic atmosphere and
attempts to undermine the renowned choir
still quoting from the times ms smith
also claimed that the choir school
misled at least one set of potential
parents
she alleged the parents of one boy were
told that he had failed his musical
audition
because the school hadn't wanted to take
a chorister who lived outside of london
as it would be harder for him to return
home for weekends under the new five-day
timetable
and if you track down marilyn smith's
letter on social media for example on my
twitter account at holy smoke
you'll read there's a bit more to that
particular story
though the school denies the allegation
the resignation letter also confirms
something that's in the public domain
but is nonetheless
very very hard to understand which is
that a philanthropist
offered to meet the cost of boarding for
the choristers
only to be turned down by westminster
cathedral
and that's in the time story too the
resignation letter adds
very tellingly that neither westminster
abbey nor saint paul's have felt
any need to downgrade to weekly boarding
quotes on the contrary some pools has
recently invested
millions in the building of new
accommodation for their choresters
anyway let's set aside for a moment the
politics of this
very nasty row what i'd like to do in
this podcast episode
is explain why musical standards at
westminster cathedral
matter so much and are not merely a
question of
aesthetics or cultural heritage
let's hear from dr garen ashton regular
contributor to this podcast
former chaplain to the queen and himself
a former boy chorister at canterbury
cathedral
gavin is speaking from his own
perspective as
a former anglican clergyman who spent
many decades
listening to beautiful catholic music
being performed
in the church of england accompanying
liturgies that were significantly
different from
the catholic ones for which they were
written and his feelings about that
music now that he's
no longer a member of the church of
england but a recent convert to
catholicism
in the spirit of making a confession
i've always been rather jealous of
westminster cathedral choir
they were so very good and admirably
good
and as all choristers and many other
people who listen to choirs know
they have their own distinctive sound i
knew partly because
i was a choral scholar who sung in a
cathedral
i was at school at canterbury and i had
a choral scholarship
there and we did all our singing in the
cathedral and i grew up in my teenage
years
singing catholic music in a catholic
cathedral
albeit as an anglican tenant
when i became a catholic so much of what
lay within
the tradition became available to me as
something i owned
not long ago i passed by tinten abbey
and stopped to pray in the ruins
and at last after decades at last they
were
they were my ruins they were my catholic
ruins they
they belonged entirely well not to me i
belonged entirely to them
and the music for the liturgy
that choirs have used to celebrate to
worship
to adore has been catholic music
and to suddenly discover that the
catholic cathedral choir westminster
essentially really the only one of its
kind was being threatened or dispensed
with or found
to be something that could be capable of
disposal
that that astonished me and i thought
what it what a tragedy that the very
moment
when i belong fully this this wonderful
voice
collection of voices obviously that
acquire has a voice
this wonderful voice is being it's being
dispensed with
i won't say thrown away i don't know
enough of the strategy
or the politics or the finances or the
history
though from what i read there's an
element of carelessness
in the dispensing of this choir but it's
genuinely unique
it's not as so many of the commentators
say adjectivally very unique
it's simply unique and for it to be
threatened and to disappear
that will be singing of course but it
was always something to know that a
westminster cathedral
not only was the lord truly present but
the very best choir
sung the very best music to the very
best god
and that was important if there's any
way at all
to save this this exercise
of inspired beauty that tears open
the skies of time and matter and allows
the pilgrim
heart to pierce time and matter
with that dart of love that somehow
music
acts as wings for then it would be so
important
to keep it and such a sadness if to the
people who were responsible for it
they didn't understand and they let it
go never to be recovered
certainly in our lifetimes and given the
journey
the trajectory of europe perhaps never
at all
that was dr gavin ashton now i did try
over the weekend to
contact westminster cathedral or
westminster diocese for comments
but as usual they couldn't be both get
back to me
but i know enough about their thinking
if you can call it that
to imagine their response to what you
just heard
their line is that all that's happening
is that the boy choruses workload is
being reduced
a little bit by two days a week so they
can go home and see their families at
weekends
and the same glorious masses will still
be sung at westminster cathedral
although not every single day because
one of the casualties of the new
arrangements is that westminster
cathedral is no longer
the only cathedral in the world to sing
a full latin mass
every day of the week doesn't that sound
reasonable
but if it's reasonable why are so many
leading figures
in the world of church music and the
classical music generally
many of them anglicans one of them are
leading jewish writer on music
norman lebret who's been covering the
scandal on his wonderful blog slipped
disc
horrified by what seems to them sheer
vandalism
the reverend marcus walker director of
saint bartholomew the great in the city
of london
wrote this on twitter the destruction of
our musical traditions
across denominations has been criminal
rarely has roger scrutin's basic
conservative insight being more obvious
good things are easily destroyed but not
easily created
it will be desperately hard to bring
these institutions back
and that was a direct response to my
tweet drawing attention to madeleine
smith's letter
described as powerful and heartfelt by
ascender maxim graham
the anglican writer whose coverage of
this miserable business has been
outstanding now these people inevitably
have different reasons for objecting so
strongly to what's happening at
westminster cathedral but what everybody
recognizes is that this is
as gavin says a unique choir
there are many professional choirs in
the world capable of singing this
repertoire to an extremely high standard
but the vast majority of them employ
adult women to tackle those punishingly
difficult soprano parts
only the boy choristers of westminster
cathedral
are able to meet the same challenge but
it's actually a greater challenge
because they have to do it day
after day after day as part of a liturgy
that's complex in its own right
how incredibly sad therefore that this
heritage
is being dismantled by the very people
who are supposed to be protecting it
the cardinal archbishop of westminster
and the headmaster of the school that
was set up
expressly to train boy choristers when
cardinal vaughan founded the choir
gavin calls it carelessness and that's
the kindest possible word you could use
i can think of many others if the boys
lose just
some of their agility some of their
purity
some of that characteristic open sound
for which westminster cathedral is
famous then
we will not hear the victoria requiem
sung
to the standard that we heard at the
beginning of the podcast
ever again and certain very complex
polyphonic works
will have to disappear from the
repertoire altogether and i think these
things are already happening
of course none of this answers the
question of what musical perfection or
near perfection has got to do with an
act of christian worship
after all every other christian church
in the world manages to get by without
this
particular apotheosis of a very
specialized repertoire
and the truth is that if you were
founding a catholic cathedral clan now
as opposed to in 1903
you wouldn't try it would just be too
difficult
but that's what cardinal herbert vaughan
did and it's thanks to him
that people whose religious imaginations
are truly stimulated by this music
can hear it sung as it was intended to
be sung by boys and men whose voices
take wing and sought all the heavens
because they have an impregnable
technique and now that technique has
been taken away from the boys
because the choir school is
inconvenienced by
the boarding arrangements for just over
20 boys
neon toxin just doesn't seem that
interested in the choir
and one of the things that's got up my
nose for a very long time
is the way that westminster cathedral
choir school ninety percent non-choruses
these days
likes to boast about how many boys it's
managed to get
into elite public schools non-catholic
ones
eaton and winchester i know this is
something that really annoyed colin
morby who was master of music at
westminster cathedral during the 1960s
and 70s
he said that cardinal vaughan hadn't
founded the choir school in order to get
more posh little boys into eaton i knew
because i told him at length that colin
was
absolutely outraged by what was
happening to the choir
which he felt had been betrayed and
sadly he died
last november i know he would have liked
to have seen
the financial aspect of this debate
properly investigated and so would i
but until that happens all we can do
really is
draw attention to westminster
cathedral's readiness to contemplate
an act of musical cultural liturgical
and spiritual vandalism
and i think i speak for quite a few
catholics when i say that
actually i couldn't care less about the
academic standards at westminster choir
school
but in the unlikely event that mr
mclaughlin
asked for my advice i think i might
suggest that he consider putting
shakespeare's sonnet number 73
on the syllabus the one that begins
bear ruined choirs where late the sweet
birds
[Music]
sang